nolan a coûté près de 200 millions de
dollars américains et en cette période
difficile les cinémas compter sur ce
film à grand déploiement pour renflouer
leurs coffres
mais disney en a décidé autrement c'est
sûr qu'un premier coup c'était décevant
la vie est une manière de tourner je
suis sûr que j'ai une mémoire à ces
langues comme l'a rappelé m
je ferai un mythe voulant devait sortir
sur grand écran en mars dernier mais la
pandémie a modifié les plans de dézoner
sauf en chine le géant a finalement
décidé d'offrir moulin exclusivement aux
abonnés de sa plateforme qui devront en
plus payer 35 $ pour le voir est ce que
c'est un modèle que disney va vouloir
pérenniser est-ce que d'autres d'autres
boîtes de production vont emboîter le
pas on avait déjà vu universe on faire
ça avec 13,2 au courant du printemps
donc est-ce que ça va être un modèle qui
va être adoptée par plusieurs
effectivement si j'étais propriétaire de
salle
je serai pas dans mon meilleur état le
film tron 2 avait généré plus de 100
millions de dollars américains en
visionnement sur demande
alors que les cinémas étaient fermés en
raison de la pandémie avec moules anne
deysine et veut aller encore plus loin
c'est une manière pour eux de fidéliser
et de cibler davantage leur audience
familiale
vous voyez avec la sortie de mulan une
sortie au cinéma en famille aurait coûté
peut-être autant pour une famille de
trois quatre enfants ou voire plus cher
que ce que disney demande à ce qu'on
paye mais non avec ce nouveau modèle
d'affaires axé sur le cinéma maison
le film moulin sera peut être piraté ce
qui pourrait nuire à disney mais aussi
aux cinéphiles qui devront être
vigilants c'est une très grande
rappaz pirates informatiques je suis
persuadé que les internautes les
utilisateurs les gens vont recevoir au
cours des prochaines semaines des
invitations à télécharger gratuitement
entre guillemets gratuitement une
version de moulins à 20,95 spéciale de
disney en vérité ça a été un site de
pirates
pour cet expert en informatique il faut
éviter à tout prix les copies illégales
de moulins surtout de ces temps ci avec
les rançons si un logiciel et toutes les
menaces convient en télétravail vous
avez de l'information de votre
entreprise maintenant en télétravail
prenez donc pas de chance payer 34 son
devoir
c'est de faire honneur à notre ferme
mourlam sera disponible sur des ce n'est
plus de vendredi
ici louis fait dépouiller même radio
canada montréal il n'aura aucune pitié
pour toi